okay off the top of my head we're still
going to remain in la ooh that's what it
says Ruth Cafe earth oh my God Earth
Cafe yes okay Earth Cafe on Melrose
Avenue in Los Angeles Quin cenal like
Los La Place whatever I never go here
I'm going to assume that this person
never goes there as well but I was
sitting in this restaurant minding my
business with honestly a hoodie on like
kind of in hiding a little bit because
it's a very sceny Place whatever and
Lana Del re approached me and she tapped
me on the shoulder and was like hey I
love your music and I passed away in
that chair um still don't know if I'm
here or there um and yeah it was a very
crazy moment and it very quickly went
from being like Star Struck to being
like I want to be your best friend so
yeah it was really cool and now I will
forever love Earth Cafe